hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7 now
we lost Zoey somehow so I guess I gotta
get back in this perfectly pristine boat
that I'm sure is mine
here we go well I couldn't have gotten
far you know how she was unconscious Joe
I mean come on I know you've been hit in
the head a few times oh hey well there
there I mean honestly and truly what did
I explain that it's not normal
huh weird huh oh you're gonna get it
alright oh-ho Joe mad Joe MyID alright
well Joe maybe you should ask what
happened to Jack and his the rest of his
family what about your your your nephew
Lucas huh yeah oddly enough considering
that this is after Evelyn is dead or if
Evelyn is dead I'm pretty sure Evelyn's
dead but this is after all of that so
honestly who knows why this is still
like spreading an infection I mean I
don't know if he's got to be that looks
like hangman's noose but like why does
why well like I know it's it's probably
perfect environment for a fungus to
thrive but I thought it was all
psychically controlled by Evelyn or
maybe Evelyn was the only one keeping it
in check and without Evelyn like
everything has gone to [ __ ] you know
what I mean like everything is just
burnt up destroyed and you know all
control is lost it's like if just to get
a nerdy reference to it if if like in
StarCraft how the zerg will run rampant
or in World of Warcraft how without the
Lich King you know all the undead will
just spread out and cause chaos on a
rampage without control and maybe that's
just what's going on here I mean in the
end it's just a fungus right so would
just do whatever it wants to do which is
be a fungus and in fact things and
cause rampage what have you but you know
you'd think that fire bombing the entire
area would have been the best Avenue for
all this wait is this wait oh wait this
is this is the Baker family residence I
[Laughter]
love you game a little
oh that's a real one okay all right
that's a real one all right hey Bosque
don't be so dramatic
all right what do we got two more okay
that's some old ray all right can I have
that can I go up here too no great all
right well I'm cut off I gotta go down
here and spear you in the gullets yeah
okay what's in here
I hope grab no grub oh damn it
refrigerators are the number one source
of grub all right fine then hope I can
make another bomb with my let's grub oh
oh
god you're so cute oh you're so cute oh
god you're so cute in my microwave oh
god is so cute I almost don't want to
pick you up and eat you welcome to my
home oh please make yourself at home I
could cook you up your big real - oh my
god oh god I'm gonna call you Steve
Steve I can't bring myself to take you
Steve all right yeah
have a good one I'll forgive you for
eating my brother that's all right
everybody gotta eat swim Oh Steve Steve
I'm sorry I even tried Steve I hope you
have a lovely day I'll never eat another
crawdad in my life even though I got
another one my inventory and I'm
probably gonna turn into goop juice
that's okay you have a day
all right Steve see ya Steve oh you
ain't Steve oh you want a bomb are you
all right well Steve is steve is doing
this thing Steve is doing Steve's thing
hey I could probably just slip by you
couldn't yeah I probably could I'm gonna
go for it oh oh oh a ski we all right
which way you go an [ __ ] oh oh okay
you're just patrolling back and forth
okay I think I can stand maybe uh it's
hard to say whoa hello where'd you come
from
I think I could yeah if I just move it's
close I'm going I'm going
ah Skelly all right okay Wow skill
whiskey whiskey whiskey we Oh Bob fluid
why why does that keep opening up V o V
does that okay all right okay well can
they make another bomb
there we go I don't any goop juice got
grub for that this scrap metal over
there but would it be worth yeah
all right it's gonna go wrong oh okay I
got to garden that one so you have to
you have to get through that one somehow
oh it left
oh it's both of them oh they just moved
oh that's that's clever of them I don't
know why they're bothering to garloo hey
Baldy where you go Oh a pathway over
there you say oh wait no that's just oh
they're just guarding that depository oh
hey watch yourself I'll bomb you I will
bomb you Oh what do you do what's your
objective here buddy
what's your objective what's your
objective your friend all right well you
large crocodilians are not welcome here
question mark all right so I got a spear
one of these guys in the butthole I
choose you
oh all right
well actually I don't think I'll be able
to get by this one either dude up
clowns ah more bomb-making fluid yes all
right I've got bombs
all right that's right you went away Oh
be back
who'd have thought okay wait ah does
this just connect both of them oh so I
could have snuck by I could have snuck
by uh without wasting a nice pair ah
okay all right well waste not want not
which is what I should have said now the
word that I want isn't what I'm saying
so I have no idea what I'd want to say
anyway I'm gonna continue on and punch
so oh my god
I'm gonna punch something hello
punchable z-- hmm okay how you gators
doing out there I can't get close to
that window all right FG yeah I love
stickball love stick bomb all right
anyway now that it got stick bomb myself
and I know that in my bag of grub is
Steve somewhere ooh I can't do it oh god
why can't I take all this totally fresh
mackerel here
oh no no no oh damn it okay all right
then
well whoa whoa something tells me going
down this ladder well might be an if fun
adventure all right seems to be a lot of
ways to get back up I'm thinking that
maybe it's gonna drop me down it seems
like a distinct possibility hey how do
you get down there I want to get down
there oh you I think maybe you get down
there by dropping down and swimming
which is not something I'm eager to do
although there might be F G's I'll stick
whoa hey hey hey well what are you doing
here
oh no oh no wait wait wait wait
and there you go Bob's your uncle whoa I
thought I saw something over there hey
stop it just roll off yeah okay oh okay
all right
oh love it
oh hello what the no oh I am out of oh I
don't have any steaks left oh geez ouch
ouch okay all right then well that
didn't work out too well
some tells me I might want to commit
some sticks to the spear variety oh man
but I don't want to waste all my sticks
for potential bombs that's rude
ludicrous all right fine then something
tells me that I should be capable of
wrestling a gator with my bare hands
but that ain't happenin oh well anyway
we commit another one of these to that
again the man death sure is final here
all right very carefully very carefully
at full breakneck speed very carefully
all right come on no no oh yeah oh yeah
oh the finisher baby ooh I got sticking
come in another one to the to the spare
RI come on now
Oh boom baby oh yes
boom it's like a walking shadow over
there
this may I mean you hit me but it didn't
it didn't hurt so hey hello well you got
a lot of bruises there goes your arm I
guess that's good enough is ahead all
right [ __ ] the throne spear and bob
fluid bob fluid oh I'm out of branches
god I shouldn't have made oh I shouldn't
have made that last one into a spear I
knew I shouldn't I should've listened to
Steve
got it gotta get gotta get fisty a
little exercise every now and then
alright so I can make my way into that
which I guarantee there's gonna be some
Gators but if I can make my way over
there there's a lot of Spears so I'm
gonna go for it
okay woo nope if I waste too many Spears
getting to this then there was no point
but hey it looks like I got a net
surplus of Spears right honk-honk
Bob fluid yes all right I gotta eat a
grub but I hope it's not Steve oh good
okay good for the dum-dum all right
where are we going okay all right then
oh oh well that ain't good okay what do
you garden
what are you garden over there anything
I'm gonna scout from above before I
actually commit to going down there but
what do you garden it looks like nothing
but I don't trust that yeah hello middle
what we got over oh all right well I
meant to use a bomb for you but I guess
oh hey wait a hand wait you gonna break
through that you'll be soon
hey delivery
you didn't notice during my [ __ ] well
it's I did need you to warm up warm up
hit from from hit II oh wait this must
all be mine because that is very clearly
the football plays that I went do I
guess everybody must have went there but
man why is everybody living in a swamp
why is everybody living in a swamp all
right hang on I gotta leave a present
it's Christmas you didn't hear nothing
what are you talking about
my app who's there I hear some slapping
oh you're not dead
how are you not dead I stopped you all
right well it's so much all right
anything else in here then I need no
sticks a garlic yes fresh
okay carrying on geez so funny boink
boink boink all right what do we got
what was that thing garden down there
was there there's something down there
but I just don't know if I should go for
it cuz seems all blocked up here I'll
look around if it's it's necessary I'll
go for it but I don't know bomb fluid
they sure are giving me a lot of that
okay yeah I'm thinking that maybe it was
over the other way hey what's going on
here dick dick dick
a grub apparently apparently a grub
wasn't enough to survive that again
roads earned are clear after clearing
the game won't what lower the difficulty
level no oh oh no way
come on what are you saying I know how
to do this yeah just what are you
thinking what are you thinking about
what are you doing I got this you think
I don't got this hang on wait I just got
to leave leave a little a little bit of
a present here blink dudu to just go ham
just got distract us guys long enough
boom oh well Merry Christmas okay well
are you all dead
good a stick a nice stick I love me a
good stick all right I'm gonna make some
medicine I guess I guess I'll make some
but at first time I ate this last grub
better not be a crawdad oh good good
good well whoa
ah
whose by me oh whoa whoa whoa that guy
grub in a box that guy did not that guy
did not have a lot of foot spa okay so
how do you get under there there's got
to be a way right it must be where that
Gator was guarding and I want to go back
because I'm pretty sure there's probably
another effigy over there and that's
probably a croc ooh
there's oh I see an effigy right there
all right you know what how my Spears I
got seven Oh hell's to the yeah all
right let's do this all right let's do
this come on one want some who want some
Wonsan yeah yeah yeah yeah okay all
right he's not going for me just yet
oh hell yeah champion what's that light
over there anything important not to the
ocean okay miss which is my first Miss
I'm allowed one miss but that's it was
this just a light yeah nothing Gordon
okay I don't think I have to hit that
guy but just in case wanna be thorough
okay what do we got over here so I don't
think this is the way to get in there
maybe it is maybe it is ooh
it is it is yes all right so what's
under here that's good oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] everything oh oh [ __ ] oh
yeah Steve Steve I'd never I would never
you out you have that delicious eye
Steve Steve you have a wonderful time
with that eye all right Steve and say
thank you see you around
now do it what's that over there how do
I get that oh I want whatever that is I
don't even know what it is I can't even
tell all right I gotta go back for that
I know I know I don't have to go back
for that I could just press on forward
but I want to just be completing this
about it for some stupid reason anything
over here
no okay I'll be right back oh no that
was a one-way path
oh titty sprinkles okay whatever I got
the champion my punching ability is a
little bit better than it was before so
that's good I probably missed out on
another small effigy but as long as I
got the champion I think that's okay all
right let's do this what is this what is
it for was what building was this what
this used to be my am all right whoa
jeez that door was awfully squishy hello
save point ah there we go there we go
all right okay hello Rock don't be a
crawdad yes the centipede a delicious
centipede alright anybody over anybody
hello this is rather ominous am I going
back up towards the house crawdad grub
yes
yes your that something is squishing its
way through the forest and I don't like
it what is that a church what how long's
this been here what the hell where the
hell am i why am I here geez why am I
making my way through all this what's
the point I don't know good good final
stand area though looks very uh very
ominous and horrifying Santa peed grub
it's almost like they're dosing me up
for something huh well gonna make
another bomb and that's that yeah you'd
think I'd find more sticks in the forest
here but apparently not okay all right
whoa whoa what the hell whoa whoa what
the hell whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't
know what happened there I think I got
quart of whoo Wookiee I don't like you
I'm gonna put a bomb right here bomb
let's not be you guys
right under your dick monk hey hey hey
look under your feet oh no your balls oh
hey Wow how am I gonna punch you answers
I'm probably not all right in your face
can I punch you I'm gonna punch you
right in your big bloated belly
Oh boom boom boom woo man that no one
was like a one punch fist alright well
you used up all my Bam's
you sack of [ __ ] alright fine then I'll
make do without you just creepy son of a
[ __ ] that ski ski ski ski alright
Sebastian Castellanos in here right now
anybody hello boxer ever G okay good my
punching power is back up just now punch
punch punch punch punch the punch of
Prayer oh hello what are you doing here
Zoe how did you get here
Zoe ah yes Zoe yes it is yes indeed it
is okay yeah what would you think that
somehow like this is the essence of Joe
bacon of Jake Jack Baker come on ma
overpower yeah there you go oh geez oh
geez it is Jack what is Jack Jack I
should recognize those hidden fists they
both like to punch real good
Jack Jack would both book Oh Jack come
on now Jack this is ridiculous
don't y'all run up young brother oh boy
Jack you think I'd be a little more
concerned as to what the hell is this
what the hell's going on
well that's one way what he couldn't
punch me to death oh geez
one one-inch punch break out of it what
the hell
god dammit don't know how I got out I
thought Jack was completely dead but I
guess maybe when maybe when Evelyn oh
look more coffins is that his common way
of just getting rid of people that he
doesn't like - throwing him into coffins
is that what it is yeah maybe when
Evelyn died like because his his
personality was like distilled into
Evelyn like psychically or whatever but
who knows what happened after he died
[ __ ] so all all these soldiers all
these soldiers with these with these
guns and one nod and shooty shooty bang
Bang's they can't they can't bring him
down but me with my fists one-on-one
whoo baby we got a stew going alright
that's all the time I got for this
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know anything down
the comments below and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]